the wizarding world exists in secret
that much is made clear early on in the
harry potter series and the conflict
that exists between wizards and
non-magic users known as muggles is a
constant focus throughout all seven of
the harry potter books the eight film
adaptations and the ongoing fantastic
beasts film franchise however despite
how integral the rift between the
magical and muggle communities is in the
series neither the books nor the movies
go all that in depth into the history of
the conflict between the world's magical
and non-magical citizens in fact the
harry potter series more or less leaves
the details of the relationship between
the muggle and wizarding societies to
the imagination the series refers to a
handful of real-life historical events
like the salem witch trials and the
first and second world wars in passing
from time to time but it doesn't dive
too deeply into how the wizarding
community eventually achieved the secret
existence that it maintains throughout
both franchises one popular harry potter
fan theory however offers up a
game-changing explanation for the
relationship between the muggle and
wizarding communities one reddit user
believes that the reason wizards were
forced into hiding is because they lost
a war with the muggles hundreds of years
prior to the events of the harry potter
series this redditer speculates that
there may have been a war between
wizards and muggles at some point during
the middle ages and the muggles somehow
emerged as the victors that defeat could
therefore be what led the wizarding
community to not only live in secret but
also in legitimate fear of muggles it
may even explain why the minister of
magic must keep the british prime
minister up to date on all matters
within the wizarding world that is to
say that the minister doesn't
necessarily do it out of courtesy but
because it's been a requirement ever
since the muggles scored their decisive
victory over wizards centuries prior
it's a compelling theory and one that
totally redefines the perceived power
balance between the wizards and muggles
of the world it raised the possibility
that muggles may have been far more
capable of taking on wizards in the
middle ages than most harry potter fans
would likely assume
i was the only one to see her for what
she was
if this theory is true it would
certainly explain some elements of the
oddly strained relationship between
muggles and wizards beyond that it might
also explain why wizards go to such
extreme lengths to hide themselves from
their non-magical brethren throughout
the series readers and audiences learn
that wizards cast spells more or less
constantly to cover their tracks from
muggles whether they're hiding entire
castles like hogwarts or dressing in
regular muggle clothing at the quidditch
world cup to look less suspicious even
so wizards take a lot of risks by
stationing important buildings or vital
passageways like the pub that leads to
diagon alley right in the middle of
london though they seem to bank on the
fact that muggles just don't notice
excuse me sir can you tell me where i
might find platform nine and three
quarters as the night bus conductor stan
shunpike tells harry and prisoner of
azkaban muggles don't see the super fast
shape-shifting bus moving at warp speeds
throughout london because they simply
aren't paying attention there's another
element of the wizarding world that
could definitely explain the ongoing
animosity between muggles and wizards
specifically the belief by certain sects
of wizards that muggleborn wizards are
inferior muggleborns meaning witches and
wizards born to non-magical parents who
unexpectedly show magical abilities are
equally as powerful as their pure blood
brethren as witches like lily potter and
hermione granger handily prove however
pure blood purists like draco malfoy
often level slurs like mud blood against
their muggle-born and half-blood
counterparts don't worry hermione gets
her revenge against draco time and time
again
[Music]
this absurd prejudice could be related
to a war in which muggles bested wizards
perhaps ancient wizarding families like
the malfoy's are still bitter that their
non-magical counterparts somehow beat
them in battle obviously none of this
has ever been confirmed in the series
but it's always fun to wonder if at one
point muggles scored a huge victory over
a bunch of super powerful witches
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you